this morning we're hearing from a
teenager who was rescued after being
trapped for more than 12 hours in Los
Angeles sewers 13 year old Jessie
Hernandez was freed yesterday after a
massive search by police fire and
sanitation crews officials call his
rescue from the maze-like tunnels a
miracle technology played a role in his
discovery Matea video shows us the boys
scary ordeal awesome Clank i'ma bye I
was ever gonna see my parents again
Jessie Hernandez recalls what was going
through his mind on Sunday when he
plunged 25 feet into a four foot wide
sewer pipe from this abandoned concrete
building Hernandez traveled through this
dark tunnel beneath Los Angeles filled
with rushing water sewage and toxic gas
more than a hundred first responders
launched a frantic search using cameras
placed on floatation devices to comb
through over 2400 feet of pipe a
breakthrough came when one camera
captured handprints along the walls of
the tunnel right away our guys were
saying okay looks like it's close he's
somewhere close by after more than 12
hours underground rescuers finally found
Jessie nearly a mile east of where he
first fell in officials tell CBS News if
he'd gone any further Jessie may have
been lost in the maze of drainage
tunnels that snake below the city
I knew they're gonna like come in or
something so they could like track me
down for the
after sanitation crews pulled him to
safety Jesse immediately asked for a
cell phone so he could personally
deliver the good news to his mother with
some humor mama life compañía for CBS
this morning media via Los Angeles that
was doing the best phone call his mother
have a lot of things but don't you guys
love the effort that it took to find him
that everybody banded together nobody
gave up and I'm so glad he's okay I just
hope when he goes to school there's no
teasing because it just lend itself to
all sorts of really inappropriate a lot
of hugging and high-fiving that's right
that's all he needs right now